the jurgen experience well
the white house commented on what i said
about vaccines
it's so funny fauci hit you up well he
didn't hit me up necessarily he
disagreed with me right yeah yeah i got
vaxed up baby did you i got one shot in
the air didn't you already get kovid
yeah i had rona i had it in october so
why did you get a vaccination
i'm a sheeple dude
part of the sheep dude i wanted it
because my antibodies i think were gone
the last time we got tested for
antibodies was
three months after
and they said they were there but they
weren't super strong so you're scared
yeah
johnson johnson no dude i'm a derna mama
you only got one though
yeah why don't you get two because my
second one is in like two weeks or a
week they have to spread you out a month
yeah 21 days i got it nothing no uh
i don't know man the whole thing like
her corona for me was weird already so i
was like i don't know i'll just do that
thing to not have it again i bought into
the system a machine well it's not being
a sheep it's i mean there's some
legitimate science behind this it's not
this is like the thing about this whole
thing
this uh people being upset at me i
didn't say
i'm not i'm not an anti-vaxx person
right in fact i said i believe they're
safe and i encourage many people to take
them my parents were vaccinated i just
said i don't think that if you're a
young healthy person that you need it
their argument was
you need it for other people so you
don't transmit the virus that makes more
sense so i'm a young but that's a
different argument
so healthy person you're not that young
okay joe thanks man you're not okay if
you were a hot chick
then you'd say i was you i'd be like
you're on the ropes
am i backed up a little bit 37. yeah
you're on the ropes bro i mean what do
you mean that's no children if you have
no children and you're a hot chick
let's be honest i'm older now you're on
the ropes okay fine it's not bad
i'm getting older i'm old as [ __ ] yeah
you are okay i'm 53 i'm old as [ __ ] i'm
almost 20 years older than you when we
celebrated your 50 year old 50th
birthday we were in detroit where were
we i forgot and it hit me hard that you
were 50. yeah i was like oh my friend is
50.
and i was starting to plan your funeral
i was like i was going through all that
stuff
i was like what are we gonna do but
honestly it doesn't bother me no because
why because you're you're in such a
great stride because i'm on [ __ ]
steroids
give them to me bro i'm on uh
testosterone replacement therapy and
every vitamin known to man i take uh a a
giant athletic greens every day i take a
[ __ ] pallet of vitamins what do i
need
here's the thing like all these people
that are saying in in in many ways
listen here's the thing these are not
like planned statements let's be real
clear when i say something stupid i'm
not thinking about what i'm going to say
before i say it i'm just saying it right
i don't have an off air an on-air voice
i don't no i have me this is it yeah
yeah i i got through the [ __ ] net and
i'm swimming in open waters okay and
that's just how i live yeah
i don't like if you say you disagree
with me i probably disagree with me too
i disagree with me all the time if you
said if someone said you have yeah
young healthy 21 year old people who eat
well and exercise are not at high risk
for coronavirus but
you should think about other people i
would say well that's a different
argument and yes that makes sense but i
would say aren't those people vaccinated
and shouldn't we vaccinate the
vulnerable people yeah and then we'd
have a different conversation the
problem is today everything's all
headlines and highlights and it's all
click bait which is fine that's the
business and i listen i have a deep
respect for real journalism i love glenn
greenwald and matt tybee and people that
stick their [ __ ] neck out and do real
journalism but there's a lot of people
out there
that have to make a [ __ ] living and
what's the best way to make a living
well here's one way take a jackass like
me
go over their podcast go for this
three-hour drunken ridiculous podcast do
we drink with dave yes no
dave smith i don't know i don't think so
no no i don't think we drank no probably
not but that's unusual yeah a lot of
times we're drinking
or we're high yeah you know and i say
stupid [ __ ] i get it and if you mind
that and you make money off of that more
power to you sure i don't care yeah i'm
happy for you right
but just don't lie just don't lie right
make get a little click baity we're good
yeah that's okay but i'm not gonna lie
let me let me say one other thing i was
going to get the vaccine i was scheduled
to get the johnson and johnson vaccine
the ufc had allocated a certain amount
of vaccines for all their employees
right and so dana said do you want to
come in and get the vaccine i said sure
what day and he said we'll set one aside
when you come in for the fights
come get accident i said okay great i
went in there i spoke to dr davidson he
said the way the cdc has the vaccines
allocated we really have to do you at
the clinic so can you come to the
hospital and i said i can't i don't have
time he said you'd have to come back on
monday i said
i'll work this out and then it got
pulled right like right afterwards
johnson's johnson thing got pulled which
now here's the thing
any medication again i'm not a doctor
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm a
cage-fighting commentator who's a dirty
stand-up comedian
who just told you i'm drunk most of the
time
and i do testosterone and i smoke a lot
of weed but
i'm not a respected source of
information even for me if i say things
i'm always going check on that jamie i
don't know if that's true right i do
that all the time right but
i at least try to be honest about what
i'm saying or what you feel yes yeah
that's what it is